cool hey so I'm gonna be talking about
vl2 a scalable and flexible data center
network and the reason I chose to give
this talk is it's actually very closely
related with the FBS paper that Alex is
gonna talk about later on and in fact
there's a small reference to the FBS
paper inside of the vl2 paper but before
that a little bit about me so I can do
and you want to get in touch with me
after this talk because my contact
information so I'm gonna cover vl2 in a
couple different ways first of all let
me start with the design goals and
really what the folks at Microsoft were
trying to achieve with vl2 and then I'm
gonna shed a little bit of light on the
history and context of where we came
from in what networks used to look like
before vl2 existed and kind of the
effects that bl2 has had and then go on
into the actual implementation of the
network that uh VL she was using and a
little bit for the discussion of how
that network enables future applications
and data centers so the design goals of
the l2 are pretty straightforward in the
sense that they wanted a scalable
network that's gonna be reliable and
still have layer two semantics so what
do they mean by a scalable Network they
mean a network with high capacity they
wanted a network where the servers were
not bound by the fabric but yet they
were bounded only by the ability for the
systems to produce traffic and they
wanted a full bisection bandwidth in
full bisection bandwidth effectively
means that at any point of the network
if you cut it or than the worst point of
the network if you cut it there's an
equal amount of bandwidth on both sides
in reliability they were aiming for
performance isolation one of the things
that the authors of the paper pointed
out is that as cloud computing is
becoming more and more ubiquitous there
are heterogeneous applications that are
running on these fabrics that don't
necessarily get along super well so how
do we make those agree and lastly they
wanted layer 2 semantics and what they
needed but by layer 2 semantics is the
ability for servers to move throughout
the network and additionally they wanted
individual servers to contact one
another
without having to go through any kind of
proxy or anything like that so a little
bit of context of where we came from so
layer to networking used to be
ubiquitous inside of data centers and
layer 2 networking is you know what most
of us called Ethernet in Ethernet we all
use MAC address
which were assigned to physical devices
they were actually burned into your neck
and as of recently when we transitioned
one gigabit networking we've left behind
hubs and csma/cd
and we've all moved into switched
networks and it requires a minimum
spanning tree in order to work and I'll
talk a little bit about that later but
there's three semantics for the kinds of
traffic you have in layer 2 networks you
have unicast traffic broadcast traffic
and multicast traffic so that's pretty
straightforward
so talking a bit about capital layer 2
networks work and look they actually
look like factories and factories are a
specific implementation of a cost
apology that requires that every layer
above the lower layer is the sum of the
capacity of that lower layer that means
that you have to scale up your switches
as you go up in the infrastructure and
that becomes very expensive very very
quickly so a little bit about the
learning aspect of how the actual
switching happens in Y that's a problem
so in learning in a layer 2 network the
server's aren't necessarily announcing
where they are learning is a passive
operation
so if server a wants to send a packet to
server B in this network
none of the switches know where to send
that traffic so that's handled in the
unique sin or in the unique case called
unknown unicast where the traffic is
actually handled as broadcast traffic so
what occurs is that that switch will
flood every port on the network except
the port that that traffic came from and
in doing that the MAC address table is
populated on all of the servers around
all the switches around the switch at
that traffic originated from until the
traffic has spread out throughout the
entire network and everyone knows where
that server that originated the traffic
from exists this can be problematic in
several senses in the sense that it will
continue to loop if we're in a graph so
how do we deal with that we use spanning
tree a spanning tree protocol was
invented by Roger Pearlman way back in
the day and it's really protocol that's
made the modern Internet work and what
that means is that we have to reduce the
network down to a minimum spanning tree
so we have to block all links in the
graph that allow loops and turn it into
a tree to prevent the loop scenario in
your traffic from constantly
going throughout the network and causing
a storm so layer three is what rides on
top layer two it's a next layer in the
OSI model and it's a little bit
different in the sense that uses IP
addresses to to locate things and these
are ephemeral they can move around the
network and additionally they don't use
a switched network they use a router
network in the sense that devices are
only making local decisions and they
don't have to be aware if the entire
topology in order to make these
decisions and there's a couple of
different ways to do this the paper
talks about OSPF which is a link state
protocol and it's a dynamic protocol but
you can also do this statically where
you pre program all the devices in the
network so switches only need to know
about the next hop and these can be
hierarchical entries as opposed to
having to have a full entry of all of
the 48 bit addresses in the network and
the way that you tie layers 2 and layer
3 together is using a protocol called
arc which uses the broadcast semantics
of layer 2 networks in order to
determine the IP address 2 MAC address
relationship in this can either be
gratuitous or a non gratuitous in the
sense that if a new device comes on the
network it can actually announce its
location so what's wrong with these
traditional designs these traditional
designs have limited server to server
capacity as I mentioned before the
factory networks as you get higher and
higher in layers those devices have to
get larger and larger and that can
become very very expensive very quickly
in in that sense there was often
segregation of these layer 2 networks in
a ACM queue article by a Bayliss and
Kingsbury they actually referenced a lot
of the issues related to layer 2
networks and how those were considered
to be failure demands and by sharding
those domains they were able to make the
network significally and in that same
sense because we have to reduce the
network down to a minimum spanning tree
reliability and utilization is a major
pain if you have n plus 1 redundancy
you're never actually going to be able
to use the entire capacity that you've
purchased your realistically only going
to be able to use 50% in the capacity or
less in a production network so what do
we want to build for we want to build
for a datacenter Network we want to
build for unpredictable traffic patterns
with heterogeneous applications in those
heterogeneous applications produce two
kinds of flows primarily
elephant which are large flows in mice
which are things like our PCs and
additionally we want fault-tolerant so
if an individual device dies in the
network it's not going to cause an
interruption of the flows in the network
so with that I'm going to talk a little
about the vl2 topology in the actual
implementation that they used so the
topology itself is a scale-out topology
as opposed to a scale-up topology in the
sense that you're adding devices
horizontally as opposed to buying very
large devices and then they use OSPF for
reconvergence and for routing the layer
3 addresses in the network and their
network also supports encapsulation
which allows them to do clever things
around flow steering and traffic
steering so I talked a little about how
layer 3 networking works traditionally
in layer 2 networking works
traditionally in the sense that it has
one canonical address for the device but
instead of that they actually added two
addresses the first address which is the
LA is designated to a physical device so
an individual switch could have in la a
server that's outside of the l2 could
have an la servers and devices within
the else you would have application
addresses AA's
and this allows us to do clever things
around building virtualized networks on
top of those physical networks another
novel insight that the topology has is
that they added an interesting mechanism
for load balancing
so they're using two mechanisms actually
the first mechanism that there's they
went with was a valiant load balancing
which for this is effectively randomized
load balancing and one of the nice
things that was pointed out in the
valiant load balancing paper is that it
can handle arbitrary traffic matrices in
a non blocking manner addition to that
they use ecmp in ecmp basically takes a
hash of the five tuple of the packet in
order to determine the next hop for that
packet and the reason why it does this
is that you get flow based load
balancing and the reason why you want
flow based load balancing is that the
TCP transmission model expects a roughly
ordered layer to ride on top of
otherwise the congestion control
algorithm shrinks the congestion window
to basically make the protocol unusable
and also they hadn't any cast enable
network in any cast is basically where
multiple devices will announce the same
la in order to handle failover and
ecmp based traffic starting the last
component that they added in the
topology was the directory server and
the directory server is a device which
Maps the LA's to the AA's and they did a
couple of clever things here the first
thing that they did is for making
changes to that they had a pack so state
machine that that went through but all
of the actual queries weren't done
against these state machines they were
actually done to replicated caching
instances and they also had active cache
invalidation to enable changing la-2a
mappings very quickly
additionally later to access controls
road on top of the directory server so
if the server was asking for a route to
specific host the directory server could
actually enforce security semantics
based on you know knowledge about the
network so what does it apology actually
look like it's a cloth topology with a
larger spine and for bisection and has
ecmp to load balance between sets of
spines so in this network there's a 4
wide spine that 4 wide spine is actually
split into two sections and the reason
why that's limited to sections is
because ecmp and commodity networking
hardware typically has a width that it's
bound by in the paper they point out
that most commodity networking gear has
a four-way with for a CMP and although
those vendors that talk about 256 way
with the severely limits the size the
DCAM and the number of entries that you
can have in there and then the actual
AA's are assigned addressing space in
different addressing space from the LA's
so what does an actual host
communicating need to do when natural
host tries to communicate it contacts
the directory server and it asks where
how do I get to this a a and there's an
agent running on the server itself that
intercepts ARP requests in that
intercepts packets in order to trigger
these directory lookups and the
directory server gives it one of the
anycast addresses that's assigned to a
pool of spines and in doing that it's
able to assign labels on top of those
spines in order to drive that traffic so
the first play bowl that it's put on top
of it is the penultimate hop and then
the top label is the spine huh
and in doing this as it traverses the
network that packet is D encapsulated
until it gets to the penultimate hop in
that case it's the actual packet itself
so you're curious as to how this is
handled and failure and that's where
ecmp and anycast come in because those
pods of spines have any caste addresses
in failure OSPF b convergence kicks in
and it results in that traffic being
redirected the other leat or the other
spine in that pod so a bit of a summary
vl2 shifts the intelligence and routing
decisions of the network from the
network itself into the hosts and it's
relatively simple in the sense that it
doesn't have a centralized controller
like so many Sdn implementations that
been proposed do and the data plane
itself is just doing very very simple
routing operations as opposed to trying
to do complex encapsulation the
encapsulation and those encapsulation D
encapsulation operations it's performing
or hard programming into the network so
a little bit of discussion of why they
made these decisions so one of the big
things that they talked about in the
papers the volatility of traffic
patterns inside of the network so given
that you can have elephants that collide
with mice how do we deal with that the
way that they talked about it in the
papers that even though these rarely
occur they need to be able to rehash
these flows in order to prevent them
from colliding in addition to that they
use the TCP congestion control to have a
non interfering network so I mean that's
ideal to have a non interfering network
worst-case scenario they move the
traffic around additionally because
they're using such simple chips they're
able to use come already hardware and
that means that they're using fixed 1ru
switches these devices are actually some
of the most reliable devices in networks
today they have like a point one percent
failure rate
and lastly the network is built on top
of proven technology so it's using
technology the Internet has actually
used for decades and decades before it
and then the replicated state machines
are using a Google or Microsoft
implementation that allows them to very
easily do this there's already built in
with the AP work that they've done
previous to this so some other benefits
that you get from this by separating out
the AAS and the LA's is you get hosts
high availability meaning that hosts can
move throughout the network very very
quickly you enable and host to control
the data plane without having to
necessarily work with the data plane and
when there's failures in the network
they typically affect less than 25% of
traffic in the network so what is the
actual effect of this today in 2015
these networks are very very common to
have virtualized layer 2 networks on top
of layer 3 fabrics in fact Amazon
recently published a patent on using
this very technology with MPLS as a post
type and it showed me that you can build
reliable scalable networks with full
bisection bandwidth out of commodity
devices and there's a handful of related
material pieces of work that been
published around this other than that
are there any questions
sorry I'm gonna fast
so in the paper in Section four they
what oh so the question was in real life
do mice and elephant collisions not
happen often so in the paper they talk
about this in section 4.6 and what they
did so there's actually two parts of the
paper the one part of the paper is the
design one part of the paper is an
actual survey of traffic patterns inside
of data center networks so they actually
took a data center fabric from Microsoft
and looked at what was occurring and
they found that traffic patterns are
basically random the best-fit traffic
pattern they could come up with at a 60%
best fit so given that the first problem
was you can never predict it so don't
even try the second part of that is in
the actual server they they rarely saw
these collisions happen in real life
where there's actual interference it was
something like less than 1% of overall
traffic